au mieux que je te mets parfois j'étais
occupée ils ont mis ça il ya quelques
années après un cambriolage
vous en faites pas les quartiers
beaucoup plus sur votre
et pourquoi los angeles j'aimerais
démarrer une nouvelle vie
un chat un chien non tu sais quoi on se
fait un barbecue qui devrait venir
on veut que cet emprunt soit convivial
et vivre on essaye de prendre soin les
uns des autres
[Musique]
vous entendez ce prix je n'entends plus
grand chose
je suis tout le temps fatigué c'est vrai
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu peux faire
courez
courez au score
le bébé
[Musique]
comment ça
mais je suis moi
[Musique]
c'est ici chez toi